pour accélérer la cadence le
gouvernement fédéral revoit son
interprétation du statut de réfugié à
l'avenir les agents des visas pour ont
statué que les personnes qui fuient le
conflit ont qualité de réfugié à moins
d'une preuve contraire cette mesure
devrait permettre de traiter l'ensemble
des demandes de réfugiés syriens reçu
jusqu'à maintenant et ce avant la fin de
l'année notre annonce aujourd'hui porte
sur nos efforts d'accélérer notre
engagement est rétablir des réfugiés
syriens et retient au canada on
désignant tous les syriens qui ont
quitté leur pays comme des réfugiés de
prime abord des réfugiés prima facie le
premier ministre sortant stephen un peu
avait déjà pris l'engagement d'accélérer
le processus d'accueil de réfugiés tout
en martelant son refus de laisser entrer
des indésirables au pays c'est ce qu'a
réitérée money cela les réfugiés devront
quand même satisfaire à toutes les
exigences en matière d'examen mangal de
contrôle sécuritaire de vérification
judiciaire
nous ferons tout cela en coupe en
réduisant la paperasse tout en
s'assurant que la sécurité du canada et
des canadiens ne soient pas mis en
question mis en question d'aucune façon
le parti libéral du canada qui a déjà
exprimé en mars dernier son souhait
d'accueillir 25 mille réfugiés syriens
d'ici la fin de l'année n'est pas
impressionnée par la décision des
conservateurs
la candidate dans quartier ville en sic
mélanie joly affirme que la plus
importante communauté syrienne du québec
réside dans son comté et quel est le
témoin de son désarroi au quotidien
selon elle cette annonce est un aveu
d'échec
c'était un un manque de volonté
politique et 2 la politique en fait de
monsieur harper était celle de faire en
sorte de d'accepter peu de réfugiés
le npd s'est pour sa part réjoui que le
gouvernement ait retenu sa suggestion de
nommer un commissaire aux réfugiés
tout en soulignant cependant
l'insuffisance du nombre de réfugiés qui
sont acceptés les néo démocrates veulent
accueillir dix mille réfugiés syriens d
maintenant et non pas d'ici un an ici
louis de belleval radio canada montréal